[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to their installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing none other than gelet
grindelwald grindelwald terrorized the
wizarding world for years
and he was one of the darkest most
powerful wizards of all time
while he does show up in the deathly
hallows film briefly
the first time we see him properly is on
screen in the fantastic beasts films
played by johnny depp grindelwald has
quite an interesting look
and when the actor was preparing for the
role he is reported to have expressed
that people kept asking him if he was
okay he has spikey pale blonde hair that
shoots straight up
extremely pale milky colored skin a
blonde mustache
half of the time and perhaps most
notable of all two different colored
eyes
the condition of having two different
colored eyes also exists in the muggle
world
and is called heterochromia
heterochromia refers to a variation
in color and when it refers to the eye
specifically it's called heterochromia
iridium
it basically means that one iris is a
different color from the other
but provided the harry potter universe
is world rich with magic
i'm hoping there's more of an
interesting explanation than that
now in my quest to figure out why on
earth grindelwald has different colored
eyes
i started to think about other
characters that also have special traits
in the ocular region the first character
that comes to mind when i think of
wonky eyes is none other than madaimudi
and the clue there that he has an
unusual eye is in his name
it's in plain sight from the order of
the phoenix
mad eye moody who had long grizzled gray
hair and a large chunk missing from his
nose
was squinting suspiciously at harry
through his mismatched eyes
one eye was small dark and beady the
other
large round and electric blue the
magical eye could see through walls
doors and the back of moody's own head
moody's eye definitely provides a
certain level of
shock value but moody didn't always have
one magical eye
once upon a time moody actually had two
matching
regular eyes just like the rest of us
from the goblet of fire
madaimudi was sitting there though there
was a very noticeable difference in his
appearance
he did not have his magical eye but two
normal ones
however moody's magical eye though quite
functional
definitely doesn't appear to resemble an
ordinary eye in any way
it sort of looks like a bot's job and
given that moody got his magical eye
many many years after grindelwald's time
i can't imagine that grindelwald's eye
is artificial in any way it looks too
natural
and while i didn't think that it was
artificial anyway it's good to cross
that option
off the list one theory that i have for
grindelwald's multi-coloured eyes
is that it is somehow linked to him
being asia
in harry potter asia as defined in the
magical world
is a gifted wizard or witch who has the
ability to see into the future with
their inner eye
seers predict prophecies which are then
recorded and stored in the hall of
prophecy
in the ministry of magic's department of
mysteries when we hear
seer we most commonly think of professor
sybel trulani
a british half-blood witch that worked
at hogwarts and came from a long line
of sears she famously predicted the
prophecy concerning voldemort
and the one with the power to vanquish
him and though she gets a bad rap as a
seer
she has actually been proven to be quite
accurate minerva mcgonagall was quite
open about her skepticism
surrounding trelawney and her abilities
as a seer
and once expressed that true seers are
extremely rare
by true i think she means seers that are
able to see visions
intentionally when they want to rather
than in the sporadic way that trelloni
functions
and it just so happens that grindelwald
could do this
from the fantastic beasts screenplay
grindelwald exhales vapor from a glowing
skull-shaped hookah
his acolytes watch as the smoke forms a
vision of the obscurus
a swirl of black and flashing red then
resolves into an image of credence
so what does being a seer have to do
with grindelwald's eyes
well we know that when trelloni has
visions on occasion
her eyes have a tendency to do some
crazy things and since
vision relates to sight i feel that it's
only natural that visions would be
connected to the eyes
in some way to me it would make sense
that you'd have an ordinary set of eyes
for ordinary things and when a vision
comes through
your eyes would adjust accordingly as
you are no longer focused on the things
in the physical world before you
but rather focused on the ethereal
aspects of your
vision this is not a confirmed thing
just a theory of mine
but i think that it bears some merit as
grindelwald is certainly more of a
seer in the traditional sense than
trelloni i think that it would make
sense that
of the two of them he would be the one
with unusual
eyes my next theory for grindelwald's
different eye colors
is that each eye is representative of
one aspect of his personality
he had two different colored eyes
because he wasn't all evil
one represented his dark side and the
other represented his
light side unlike voldemort grindelwald
had a certain element of humanity
surrounding his character he was capable
of things like love
and empathy and so it sort of makes
sense that this division of character
would manifest itself
in the form of two different colored
eyes each representing one
side of himself and though i feel as
though each eye represents one aspect of
his personality
i think the eye color itself has an
inverse relationship with the
characteristic
that it is meant to represent his brown
eye which is
darker than the other represents the
side of grindelwald with more humanity
and in contrast his light eye which is
visibly more jarring
represents the darker side of
grindelwald grindelwald began
experimenting with dark magic
at a very young age and was even
expelled because of it
he tyrannized both the wizarding and
muggle worlds and did some truly
terrible things
but from his perspective it was all for
the greater good
for the greater good was a slogan that
grindelwald adopted at the beginning of
his
regime he developed the expression with
dumbledore
and it was meant to say hey in the end
this will all work out for everyone
but for now expect some chaos however
grindelwald used his slogan to justify
some truly horrific actions
it was engraved on the entrance of
nurmengard and it quickly became more of
a symbol of hate
than anything else he truly believed
that his actions would be eventual
benefit
to everyone which is why i don't think
that grindelwald was pure evil
only very disillusioned he simply wanted
wizards to rule over muggles
witches and wizards were his people and
he felt that they should be in power
it's as simple as that the more you deep
dive into grindelwald's character
the more it seems to make sense that his
contrasting emotions
would be manifested in his physical
appearance in some way
furthermore experimenting with dark
magic has been proven to alter your
physical appearance
as we've seen with voldemort and though
grindelwald didn't create
a horcrux he is said to have
experimented with some twisted magic
so i can see how this might have
affected him physically
we haven't yet received a proper
explanation for grindelwald's different
eye colors
which means that we can only speculate
however the following interview with
johnny depp
who plays grindelwald does help to give
us some clarification
referring to depp's character
grindelwald he is asked the following
he now has as one of your co-stars
referred to a
scary eye one eye rather different from
the other
does that have a backstory is that just
creepy
to which he responds it's a character
choice i saw grindelwald as more than
one
if you know what i mean i almost felt
like he's maybe two people
he's twins in one body so a gamy eye is
more like the other side of him
sort of like a brain for each eye an
albino twin
and he's somewhere in the middle what
this confirms is that his eyes are
connected to the internal duality of his
character
we don't have any further information on
how this was actually achieved
but perhaps we'll get some answers in
the upcoming fantastic beasts films
of which three are still on the way and
that's it for this video
if you guys enjoy the content please
like the video and subscribe to the
channel
until next time you're a wizard howdy
you